you pop out of the ocean and hear the
faint yells of the lifeguard
the whole beach panics
you turn around
something lurks in the water
before you can say loch ness monster a
tall shadow emerges
lunging with its sharp teeth headed your
way
if the stixxasaurus were around today
where would it live
what would your potential demise have to
do with being crushed by stones
and why could it be more afraid of you
than you'd be of it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the stixxasaurus was alive
technically speaking this marine reptile
wasn't a dinosaur although it sure swam
the earth alongside many of them
styxosaurus lived 70 to 85 million years
ago in the late cretaceous period
long before humans set foot on the
planet
and this monstrosity measured 10 meters
in length
its prominent neck accounted for close
to half that size
at 5 meters that's almost three times
longer than the neck of the average
giraffe
and this freak of nature was no light
weight either
with more than
3600 kilograms of reptilian goodness
it was as heavy as a killer whale
so how come this enormous reptile
wouldn't swallow you whole
scientists have found fossils of this
ancient behemoth in what is now kansas
and south dakota
so if stixxosaurus were alive today it
would mainly inhabit the coasts of north
america
but it's unlikely you'd see this beast
in its full size
all you'd be able to spot is its head
and a good chunk of its long neck
protruding from the water
that's because stixxasaurus would bury
its large turtle-like body in the
murkiest and darkest waters making it
appear much smaller than it actually is
this would reduce the chances of it
being detected and would make it seem
less intimidating to the fish and squid
it will later munch on
this feasting would be pulled straight
from a horror movie
as styxosaurus shut its mouth around its
prey sharp teeth would intermesh with
each other and fully trap the animal
inside
like a cage from which there's no
escaping
but the process wouldn't quite end there
some of the stixxosaurus fossils were
found with over 200 small stones in
their bellies
these stones could have served as a
ballast helping the prehistoric
creatures sink closer to the ocean floor
but it's more likely that the rocks
aided with digestion
yeah while the teeth of the stixxosaurus
evolved for seizing slippery prey
they weren't particularly effective at
cutting through flesh
so this behemoth would swallow its
still-living prey whole
and the stones in its belly would take
care of crushing bones and rubbing off
scales
now if it set its eyes on you would you
end up rocking and rolling in its
stomach
well
the head of an average stixxasaurus
would be around 50 centimeters long with
a snout of about 30 centimeters in
length
that means if you happen to be an
average sized adult this sea reptile
wouldn't want to try swallowing you
whole
you wouldn't fit in its mouth
now if stixxasaurus could swallow you
whole you'd experience a sudden
inescapable darkness as you slide down a
long neck and land in a stone pit
and that's where you'd finally be
pummeled to death with rocks
what a bizarre way to go
it's a good thing this behemoth wouldn't
be big enough to swallow you in one
piece
but this doesn't mean you'd go
completely unharmed
the stixxosaurus might be trying to take
a bite out of you in self-defense
your best bet for surviving would be to
do what you would do during a shark
attack
the worst thing you could do is panic
and splash around
that would only peak the stixxosaurus's
curiosity
instead try to look as big and
intimidating as you possibly can
of course that's easier said than done
when facing a predator 45 times your
size
if you managed to gain the
stixxosaurus's respect and it left you
alone
it could settle for the smaller portion
options
but sticking to fish and squid would
make it run into some fierce competition
namely sharks and killer whales who also
gorge on similar sea life
but here's a twist
with this potential swimming buffet
around
the oceanic predators of today might add
a new item to their menu
and this would be
you guessed it a generous serving of
stixxasaurus
that's because this giant reptile was
never really the apex predator its
intimidating appearance might suggest
prehistoric sharks with a size similar
to the modern great white were
styxosaurus's natural-born enemy and
very likely aided in its extinction
and on top of being hunted by ancient
sharks it seems like the stixxosaurus
also wasn't immune to the temperature
changes in the ocean that were brought
on by the changing climate
yikes
our long-necked friend could not have
chosen a worse time to stick around
but here's a twist it's actually how
cold the oceans currently are that might
give the stixxasaurus trouble
during the cretaceous period the
planet's oceans had an average
temperature of 37 degrees celsius
the styxosaurus will have a real hard
time withstanding the cooler waters that
can be found off north american coasts
today
unless it had adapted through evolution
not even warmer tropical waters would be
able to provide its sufficient heat
if the styxosaurus was around today it
might not pose the greatest of threats
to us ocean loving humans if anything
the risk to this behemoth's survival
would go beyond killer whales and sharks
yeah you can bet our more avant-garde
foodies would also be dying to give
stixxasaurus a taste
seeing as it's a reptile odds are it
would have the sweet and juicy flavor of
an iguana
with the fish-like texture of its
favorite marine life
you know putting aside the risk of
parasites viruses and salmonella that
comes from eating reptiles
it actually sounds quite delicious
which leads me to wonder what if we
raised dinosaurs for food i can't be the
only one who's craving a dilophosaurus
tartare
that's a story
for another
what if
you